comme des millions de canadiens allison
se rend à son bureau chez elle 100% du
temps de travail à distance forcé mais
agréable c'est ce qui apparaît
déplacement le matin l'après midi pour
revenir les pieds aller au bureau et
puis ça les pros
en fait selon un sondage publié
aujourd'hui six canadiens sur dix
veulent travailler au moins en partie à
distance l'évolution depuis le printemps
est marqué à l'époque sur 100 personnes
trente trois personnes de retourner au
travail
aujourd'hui les études montrent que
c'est juste une pourcentage et 14% qui
ont vraiment envie de retourner ce qui
se confirme aussi c'est que ni les
employés ni les gestionnaires ne sont
tentés d'en faire un peu moins en
télétravail la grosse crève c'est ce
qu'à la productivité va baisser et les
sondages même avant la corrida indiqué
que non même beaucoup de recherches
indiqué qu'à l'arrêt gare la presse que
la productivité avait augmenté et
aujourd'hui 18 % des québécois ne
veulent pas revenir au bureau même
proportion en ontario mais 14% sont
anxieux à l'idée d'un retour ils sont 8%
à ressentir cette anxiété dans les
provinces de l'atlantique et qui dit
engouement pour le télétravail dit
désertification du centre ville avec une
grande crainte pour toute une économie
locale
ici au pied des tours à bureaux dans le
quartier des affaires de montréal les
tours pourraient être remplies au car
tout en respectant les mesures
sanitaires
on en est loin selon la chambre de
commerce pour deloitte vide 2% dans
l'édifice sun life 5% pour la tour kpmg
un retour au moins partiel ferait aussi
du bien à allison qui travaillent
normalement au centre ville et un mixte
des deux je pense que c'est réaliste
on va voir ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains mois je pense qu à personne
c'est ce qui va arriver ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal